plus de trente mille véhicules par jour
circuleront désormais sur cette section
de la rd 30 une avancée attendue dans ce
secteur encombré
l'accès à la rn 12 se veut plus facile
et plus fluide coupe comme ça le flux de
circulation de ceux qui empruntent cette
route départementale 30
je rappelle vient de poissy pour aller
vers elancourt donc franchir ou donner
accès à la nationale 12
vous pouvez maintenant avoir un trafic
séparés entre ce que l'on appelle le
trafic de transit et le trafic qui est
plutôt plaisir war la rd30 élargie à
deux fois deux voies passe sous le
giratoire des gâtines la circulation
s'effectuera sur une file dans chaque
sens jusqu'à l'achèvement des travaux
sur l'ensemble du tracé une mise en
service prévue pour la fin de l'année
je dois bien pour noël 2010 est on aura
terminé les gros ouvrages et la
circulation pourra être donnée aux
véhicules à moteur
pourquoi je fais ce distinguo parce que
arrive deux autres ensembles qui sont
des passerelles pour la circulation
douce parce que vous avez une voie verte
une voie verte et 2 passerelle piétons
et cycles qui permettront le
franchissement de la n12 pour rejoindre
elancourt
fin des travaux prévue pour 2018